[موسيقى]
لا تصدقوا المنجمين فهم دجالون تقول
الحكايه ان جنديا قصد عرافه لتقرا كفه
فقالت له انك ستعيش طويلا وان كلمه سعدك
ستكون بين الياء والسي ورقم حظك
105 فقتل بعد ايام قليله بقذيفه ياسين
105 الم اقل لكم لا تصدقوا المنجمين الى
العناوين يرفضون مقاومه المحتل ومستعدون
لاستعاده الحرب
الاهليه ابو عبيده سيد الرجال في الاعلام
التونسي والاعراس المصريه
طفل يستشهد كل عشر دقائق وايلون ماسك
اسرائيل تحول الاف الفلسطينيين
لمقاومين الاحتلال يحول مستشفيات غزه الى
مقابر والكلاب تنهش جثث
الشهداء غزه بين نكبت مع اختلاف في
الالوان بين
الصورتين اردوغان يهدد نتنياهو باهات
المظلومين ونصر الله يدعم غزه بالدعاء الى
جانب القتال والمقاومه والشهداء
والدماء القمه العربيه الاسلاميه لم تؤيد
العدوان على غزه وطالبت
[موسيقى]
بوقفه اسمعني يا معتادي اسمعني يا معتادي
مادام الله سندي مادام الله سندي
انا قد التحدي انا قد التحدي لو كل العالم
ضدي لو كل العالم ضدي انت والاكبر منك صعب
اني
يهزون انت والاكبر منك صعب اني زوني تحيا
تحيا تحيا
فلسطين تحيا تحيا تحيا فلسطين تحيا فلسطين
ويسقط الصهيون
مرحبا قبل القيل والقال والجواب على
السؤال وقبل ان نتحول في احسن الاحوال الى
محللين جيو بيو ثيو استراتيجيين لما يحدث
في فلسطين وفي اسوا الاحوال الى مشاهدين
متفرجين فلنس انفسنا انا وانتم ماذا قدمنا
لغزه لابناء جلدتنا وعقيدتنا وعشيرتنا
ماذا قدمنا لصمودهم وجهادهم ونضالهم غير
هذه الكلمات التي لا تطعم من جوع ولا تؤمن
من خوف هل يليق بنا ان تسبقنا الدواب في
اغاثه
الملهوف اسمحوا لي ان اتقدم باسم انسانيه
البشر بكل الشكر والعرفان للحمير والبغال
المحترمه التي استجابت لنداء الواجب
وشاركت في اغاثه اهل الشرفاء المظلومين في
[تصفيق]
غزه مع انتفاخ الصحف والمنصات الرقميه
بمواقف تنتقد المقاومه وتحملها مسؤوليه
ماسي
الفلسطينيين نتذكر ميشيل عون وسمير جعجع
مع حفض الالقاب حين تقاتلا على اداره
المنطقه المسيحيه في لبنان وليس على
مقاومه غزو اسرائيل للبنان الذي تعاونا
معه كل بمقدار ومن موقعين مختلفين فدمر
مناطق الوسط المسيحي وتسببا
بهيمنة حسب اخر انتخابات الزعيمين
المسيحيين الاكثر شعبيه في لبنان ثم قد
ياتيك مناصرون لهما او
لاحدهما مثل المسؤول القوتي شارل جبور
ليقول لك ان حماسه مجرمه لانها تسببت بما
يجري في غزه متناسيا حروبه العبثيه على
السلطه في الخلاصه اذا كنت بتايد منظمه او
نظام عم تعمل حروب عبثيه في ريت تبيع
المقاومين في غزه سكوتك بقول بهيج مثل ما
المجازر عم تتك مين عم تحكي عن حماس يعني
اه انت تبنيت الروايه الاسرائيليه يلي حتى
الامريكان والس ان ان في وع قصه المجازر
ومادري شو ما عم نقف عم نحكي وقائع
الامريكان تعت مراسله سي ان ان ق سبعت
ومعرفه البيت الابيض في حدا في حدا قدر
ينف هول الشباب والصبايا السهرانين 250
واحد قتلوا
شار بستغرب ه الكلام زعلان على 250 واحد
اسرائيلي وقد ايه صار راي 100000 واحد
بغزه اطفال كي بناخذ الامور مش نخذ الامور
انت بلشت لك لو سمعت منك ايداني على
الاطفال وع المجازر كنت بقطع لك اياها
يعني 250 بس جاي تحكي بال 250 وما سمعتنا
كلمه عن 10000 سؤال الحلقه اليوم حول
الامام عمر المختار قائد ثوره تحرير ليبيا
من الاحتلال الايطالي هل هو برايكم شيخ
الارهابي
الذين تسببوا لشعبهم بالضرر والايذاء ام
انه شيخ الشهداء الشرفاء دونوا تعليقاتكم
ليقراها الجميع يا عمر لماذا لا تستسلم
احصل على افضل الشروط مع الايطاليين طريق
الامان للخروج الامان الى اين الى مصر الى
مصر لاختبئ يا صاحبي انهم حكومه هذا البلد
لا ياخذون الارض في النهار وبعون الله
نسترد نحن في الليل انت وحيد قطعت بك
السبل عن بقيه البلد وعزلت عن بقيه العالم
في عصبه الامم لا احد يهتم هذه المعركه لا
نحاربها في عصبه الامم نحاربها هنا على
هذه الارض لن تقو على هذه الحر دمك ازاء
فولا ذه لكل امرئ يومان يومه هو ويوم
اولاده اولادك ضحيا الجوع في معسكرات
الاعتقال يموتون لانك تصر على القتال انهم
رهائن هذه الحرب ولكن لا احد منهم يخون او
يطالبني بالاستسلام لانهم يعرفون ان
استسلامي خيانه لهم ربما كانت هذه اخر
فرصه ل لتطلب السلام الشريف يسرقون ارضنا
يدمرون بيوتنا يقتلون الابرياء وتسمي ذلك
بالسلام والله لن يفسدني سلام ذلك الرجل
اذا فلنعد نعم عودوا هذا واحد من احفاد
شيخ المجاهدين عمر المختار وان بعدت
المسافات
فالاعتدال سه على بخير احنا بنزل علينا
الصاروخ وزنه 1000 طن بنقول الله اكبر
ونصر المقاومه بنشي شهدائنا بنقول بالروح
بدمنا بدي يا اقصى اليوم ننا اخذنا عتقنا
مرحله تحرير مرحله التحرير بدها دماء بدها
شهداء احن مستعدين يا رب يا رب خذ من
اطفالي حتى ترضى اليوم انا ودعت اختي
شهيده اخت البكر ممرضه في مستشف في مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى وخلي حكامنا العرب يتفرجوا
علينا خلي حكامنا العرب يتفرجوا علينا
بقول المقاومه تستمر الناطق باسم كتائب
القسام ابو عبيده هو سيد الرجال في
الاعلام التونسي واغنيه الاعراس في ام
الدنيا ما السر في هذا الرجل الذي اثر
قلوب الملايين احنا نفتقد او نشتاق او
نعشق صوره البطل الشجاع اللي يحكي على
لسان المقاومه يحكي على الشعب الفلسطيني
وعلى لسان الشعب العربي الكل وعلى الشعب
العربي الكل للعالم الكل يقول اللي ما
يقولوش القاده العرب الكل الان البطل لحما
ودمن سيد الرجال قائد القوات ابو
المناضلين هذه هذه زريقه اع الرجوله اللي
باش زرقها لولادنا الصغار ابو عبيده ابو
عبيده راسمو كاميرا فون اخضر كيتكلم تحس
الرجله والقرحه ابو عبيده بالنسبه لينا
نحى الذل على الامه العربيه الاسلاميه
فهذا الملثم يقول الحق ويقول الصدق ويقول
عن قناعه وتحسه صادق وتحس الايمان عنده
وكما قال ابو عبيده ويقول في كل مداخله له
انه لجهاد نصر او استشهاد متدينون يهود
يغنون في الاعراس الاسرائيليه مطالبين
باباده الفلسطينيين فيما يتغنى المصريون
في اعراس وافراحهم الشعبيه باسم الملثم
بما توفر من اصوات وكلمات
مرتجله
[موسيقى]
ملك
لو سم في
وبنا ابو عبيده يا عمهم يقسمهم كلهم ابو
عبيده يا الحطيب ابو عبيده يا الحبيب اضرب
واحر يب يا ابو عبيده يا فخر
العرب يا راعب قلوب الصهاينه لك منا كل
الاحترام يا ابو عبيد
يا صقر قسام ابو عبيده اسمك زلزال ل تنضرب
فيك الامثال داعش على المضغوطين انت يا
سيدي
الرجال نعرف الذين يتمنون النصر لاسرائيل
على الفلسطينيين يقول مراقب حتى ولو كتموا
ذلك في قلوبهم نعرفهم من مواقفهم لكن اليس
لهؤلاء من الابناء والاحفاد من يذكرهم بم
هد لفائف اكفان الاطفال
البيضاء هم رحلوا الى السماء فالى اين
انتم
سترحلون جد يحمل احفاده الشهداء الاطفال
سلاما الى رسول الله محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم ورساله قب الرسول وقولوا له يا رسول
الله فهمتك خذت شعب غزه يا رسول الله
جابوا الرسول وقولوا له يا رسول الله
خ شعب غز رسول للرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
يا س الام خلتنا في غزه يا رسول الله
قبلونا يا رسول الله كل عشر دقائق يستشهد
طفل واحد على الاقل دون ان تتمكن الامه من
اكرامهم لا دفنا ولا محاسبه ولا حتى تعزيه
في صفحات الوفيات فنظمه الصحه العالميه
اكدت ان كل ع دقائق يقتل طفل نتيجه الصراع
القائم هنا في هذه البقعه المدمره تلتفت
اعين الملايين حول العالم الى ماساه مليون
طفل محاصرين تحت وطاه الحرب والهجمات
المستمره محاوله ايصال صرخاتهم لكن دون
جدوى هل يعتقد الاسرائيليون انهم ينهون
المقاومه بقتلهم المدنيين
الفلسطينيين ام انهم يمدون بعشرات الاف
المتطوعين المستقبليين سؤال ذكي من مالك
منصه اكس تويتر ايون
ماسك راقبوا معنا هذا الجحيم لنكتشف معا
انه واقع محيط المستشفى الاندونيسي في غزه
وليس لقطه من الحرب العالميه
داخل المستشفى هذا هو المستشفى هذا هو
المشهد داخل المستشفى الله
اكبر تقول الحكمه الفلسطينيه باللكنه
الغزاويه عندما تجعل ام شهيد تتمنى
الاستشهاد الجماعي فابشر بقرب سقوطك احنا
نجينا بس عننا 15 شهيد في الدار قولي لي
ايش حيعملوا لنا العرب احنا براميل رموا
على الناس براميل متفجره رموا على الناس
عشان ما يطلع ولا انسان حي طيب ايش سوينا
يعني ابراج بحالها ب محتاله بينزلوها فش
فيها ولا واحد ينتمي لاي فصيل طب ليه
تعملوا فينا كده ما تب دونا
ارموا علينا كيماوي كلياتنا ليش بتخلونا
نحزن على حبايبنا ارموا علينا كيماوي
كلياتنا
وريحونا ليش بتعملوا هيك فينا وتحزن على
اولادنا لما الواحد انا ابنس عريس ما بقو
شهر خاطب بقو شهر استشهد بالاذن من السيده
فيروز واغنيتها لريما حتى تنام اطفال غزه
لا تغنى لهم يلا تنام ولا تروى لهم حكايه
ليلى والذئب فضاع شخصيا تدهم ليلهم لتوي
على
طفولتهم يا با خلص مطول بس بقوللك تعال
افرج طيب
[موسيقى]
يلا جو بايدن انتوني بلينكن هل تسمعان
صراخ الاطفال وانين الجرح في مستشفى
الشفاء نداء انساني من طبيب الانسانيه
النرويجي في غزه جيلبير ماديس لكن للاسف
لم يسمع العالم النداء واقتحم جيش
الاحتلال مجمع الشفاء ولم يجد فيه الا
اللون الابيض اثواب الاطباء البيضاء
والشاش الابيض واكفان الشهداء لكن السنه
ضليل واصلت اجترار روايات الزيف والشر حتى
اللحظه الاخيره نتنياهو الذي لم يجد نصرا
على المقاومين فوق الارض وتحتها لن تعوضه
صوره سيلفي لجنوده في المستشفيات بين
جثامين النساء والاطفال الشهداء هكذا يضع
يعني هذا الرجل الطفل الذي قصف داخل
العيادات الخارجيه في مستشفى الشفاء الطبي
يضعه بجانب شقيق
وبعد فشل المنظومات الاسرائيليه في العثور
على اي وجود للمقاومه وادواتها في
المستشفى القى جيش الاحتلال القبض على
رزنامه الاسبوع ولا سما العقيد السبت الذي
قاد عمليه السبت الشهير طوفان الاقصى
فالذي والمسكنه بلغت بهم ان اعتقدوا ان
جدول الدوام الاسبوعي للموظفين في
المستشفى هو لائحه باسماء قيادات كتائب
القسام في
الميدان
weer i
will in our b this list says we are in
operation the operation against israel
started in the of october this is a list
where every terrorist writes name
تفتقد الامه الاسلاميه زعيم الضالين في
قريش ابا جهل الذي رفضت مروءته اقتحام بيت
قائد المسلمين رسول الله محمد عليه الصلاه
والسلام كي لا يروع بناته رضي الله عنهن
اما ابو جهل الجديد فقد لاحق الاطفال الى
المستشفيات وحولها الى مقابر جماعيه
والكلاب الحقيق قيه هذه المره تقتحمها
ايضا لتنهش بالجثث المقابر الجماعيه فعلا
ما كانت تتحدث عنه وزاره الصحه ان هذه
المستشفيات في حال توقفها تتحول الى مقابر
جماعيه بالامس مستشفى الاندونيسي تحدث انه
يعد العده
لدفن عشرات الشهداء ممن لا يستطيع حتى
الخروج بهم الى المقابر يعد العده الى
دفنهم في ساحه المستشفى نحن نموت بصمت في
مستشفى الشفاء او الناس هناك يموتون بصمت
اكثر من 100 الا نازح داخل مستشفى الشفاء
الان يموتون كان حديث
ل اليوم
لوزاره الداخليه هنا تقول ان الكلاب دخلت
المستشفى تنهش في الجثث الوضع كارثي
ايميلي كالي كالاهان ممرضه امريكيه في
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود غادرت غزه لكن قلبها
ما يزال هناك مع المظلومين الشرفاء تقول
للس ان ان وتضيف لو امتلكت ذره مما بقلوب
اهل غزه من ايمان ساموت سعيده اطال الله
بعمرها
in absol heartbeat my heart is in gaza
it will stay in gaza the palestinian
people that i worked with both our
national staff in the office as well as
my staff at indonesia hospital were some
of the most incredible people i've ever
met in my life we lost a nurse weekend
one um he was killed when the ambulance
outside the hospital was blown up and i
was texting them when we got the
evacuation orders and i said did any of
you move south did any of you get out
like are any of you coming down this way
and
رفض اطباء وممرض مجمع الشفاء الطبي
مغادرته حتى اللحظه الاخيره وما زالون
عينه من افراد الجهاز الطبي الذين يرفضون
ترك مرضاهم والجرحى همام اللوح طبيب غزي
وتلك كانت اخر رسائله قبيل استشهاده
بالقصف
الاسرائيلي عضو المجلس الاسرائيلي الحربي
المصغر الوزير ا دختر يعلنها بكل فخر نحن
نصنع الان نكبه
غزه مل ب ن غ
نز من حق الناس ومن طبيعه البشر ان تخاف
وتنح عن بيوتها وان يكون وقف اطلاق النار
اوللا
اولوياتها لقد فعلناها عشرات المرات في
لبنان ونقلنا اهلنا عندما كنا اطفالا من
مكان الى مكان هربا من الحديد والنار
والقصف والبطش
والحروب الاشاده ببطوله المقاومه وبانها
حولت قطاع غزه الى مقبره لدبابات وجرافات
قوات الاحتلال الغازيه لا تحجب ان شعب غزه
يواجه ح حربا شبه نوويه وان صراخه حق
وخذلانه جريمه وخيانه غزه بين نكبت مع
اختلاف في الالوان بين الصورتين وكان
التاريخ يعيد نفسه مئات العائلات تنزح من
شمال غزه باتجاه الجنوب حيث اعلن جيش
الاحتلال سيطرته على شارع صلاح الدين
جنوبي مدينه غزه واعلن ممرا امنا
للمواطنين للخروج من مدينه غزه وشمال
القطاع العائلات التي بقيت في شمال القطاع
لاحقها القصف الاسرائيلي الى اماكن نزوحها
في مدارس الاونروا لكن الاطفال الذين
ولدوا في بيئه مقارعه الدمار يحولونه الى
العاب وملاهي تتحول هذه الحفره فورا من
حفره صاروخ اسقط على المدرسه الى لوحه
تزلج للاطفال داخل مدارس النازحين هنا غزه
و هنا شمال القطاع وهذه واحده من
الاستهدافات
[موسيقى]
المستمره هل يظن رئيس فرنسا ان العرب
كالاطفال
يتذكرون اخر موقف فقط وينسون ما سبق فبعد
ان هرع الى تل ابيب واعلن دعمه الكامل
لاسرائيل في حربها على ما وصفه بالارهاب
ودعا الى اطلاق حرب دوليه على مقاومه حماس
بدل ايمانويل ماكرون خطابه امام
الانتقادات الداخليه والخارجيه فبادر الى
تنظيم مؤتمر انساني فجائي لاغاثه غزه ثم
الى الدعوه لوقف شامل لاطلاق النار دون ان
ينسى تحميل المقاومه مسؤوليه تجرؤا على
طلب الحريه والاستقلال كل ما يحدث الان هو
نتيجه لما قامت به حركه حماس في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هناك العديد من الماسي
الانسانيه تجرى الان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه اسرائيل لها الحق في الدفاع عن
نفسها ولكن في نفس الوقت ان في اطار
احترام القانون واحترام حقوق الانسان يجب
ان يكون هناك هدنه انسانيه في اسرع وقت
ممكن ويجب ان يكون وقف لاطلاق النار بعد
دعوه ماكرون الى وقف المجزره الاسرائيليه
غضب نتنياهو واعطر رئيس فرنسا درسا في
الاخلاق معتبرا تصريحاته خطا فادحا سياسيا
واخلاقيا فسارع ماكرون الى استرجاع
تصريحاته معتبرا انها فهمت خطا فاسرائيل
لم تقتل 11 الف مدني عمدا في غزه يقول
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان يتوعد
بنيامين نتنياهو باهات المظلومين و امين
عام حزب الله السيد حسن نصر الله يشدد على
دعم غزه بطلب الدعاء لها ايهن يا نتنياهو
هذه هي ايامك الجيده التي ينبغي ان تفرح
بها تنتظرك ايام تختلف عن اليوم اهات
اولئك المظلومين لا يمكن ان تدعك وشانك
ستكون عاقبتك الخسران الى جانب القتال
والمقاومه والشهداء والدماء انا ادعوكم
ايضا الى الدعاء الدعاء لا تستخفوا
بالدعاء عقدت في الرياض قمه عربيه اسلاميه
استثنائيه دع بيانها الختامي جميع الدول
الى وقف تصدير الاسلحه والذخائر الى
اسرائيل على خلفيه الحرب في غزه القمه
انتقدها كثيرون داخل فلسطين وخارجها ودعا
الزعيم اللبناني وليد جنبلاط الى حل جامعه
الدول العربيه بعد فشل القمه في فتح معبر
رفح لكن تفاءلوا بالخير تجدوه فالق على
الاقل لم تؤيد العدوان الاسرائيلي بل قالت
انه يجب ان يتوقف اجتمع القاده العرب
والمسلمون في قمه مشتركه بين جامعه الدول
العربيه ونظمه التعاون الاسلامي لارسال
رساله موحده ان هذه الحرب يجب ان تتوقف
القمه ستتابع في المحاكم الدوليه جرائم
اسرائيل التي ارتكبتها والتي تظل ترتكبها
في غزه وكل فلسطين تطالب من المدعي العام
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه استكمال التحقيق
بجرائم الحرب والجرائم ضد الانسانيه التي
ترتكبها اسرائيل من ايجابيات القمه ايضا
اعتبار الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد ان
اسرائيل بجرائمها تفوقت على نفسها فقط ان
الطارئه في قمتنا اليوم ليس العدوان ولا
القتل فكلاهما مستمر
وكلاهما ملازم للكيان وسمه
له لكن الطارئ هو تفوق الصون الصهيونيه
على نفسها في الهمجيه الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي اعرب عن رفضه الاستمرار
الحصار على قطاع غزه في ظروف
استثنائيه يمر الوقت فيها ثقيلا على اهالي
غزه من المدنيين الابرياء الذين يتعرضون
للقتل والحصار في الخلاصه ان مجرد اللقاء
والتواصل بين قاده الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه امر طيب جدا
اناديكم اشد على اياديكم وابوس
الارض تحت نعالكم واقول افديكم السياسيه
الايرلنديه ماري لو ماكدونالد لا ترضى
باقل من طرد سفير تلبيب من بلادها واحاله
اسرائيل الى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه رئيس فنزويلا نيكولاس مادورو يرى
في الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه حمله
اباده دينيه ويقول الدور سياتي بعد
المسلمين على المسيحيين
الكث
nazi
pal
[موسيقى]
ختاما صحيح انه للمره الاولى في تاريخ
الصراع مع اسرائيل تكون المقاومه
الفلسطينيه صاحبه الهجوم الاول وانه للمره
الاولى تصل المقاومه الى عمق مستوطنات
وغلاف غزه ثم تعود الى قواعدها مع عشرات
الاسرى من جنود الاحتلال وانه للمره
الاولى يقدم فيها الفلسطينيون برهانا
ميدانيا ساطعا ان الجيش المخيف يقهر ويدحر
وهو قابل للانكسار لو قدرت للمقاومه
امكانيات الردع الجوي لكنها ليست المره
الاولى التي نخذل فيها نحن العرب
والمسلمون غزه وكل
الفلسطينيين لكن الفلسطينيين ستتواصل
حياتهم وستستمر قضيتهم معنا او
بدوننا الى اللقاء الحمد لله يا جماعه انه
الله سقانا من ماء المطر ونحن نحب الحياه
اذا ما استطعنا اليها سبيلا مباريات كره
قدم داخل مدرسه تحوي نازحين في مدينه خان
يونس هنا في قطاع غزه يعني في هذه الاوقات
نعاني وفي هذه اللحظات القصف والعدوان على
قطاع غزه هنا نتابع في هذه الاجواء
الترفيهيه كره القدم هي الكره الترفي حلوه
يا عيني يا عيني يا عيني يا عيني الهدف
الثاني على طول كره حلوه وهدف ثاني وهدف
[موسيقى]
جميل
ه